bonsoir
alors moi j'ai moins l'habitude que les
autres de faire tout ça parce que moi je
travaille avec un langage qui n'est pas
le même que vous qui est celui des
images mais néanmoins ce soir je vous
parlais de mon travail que je fais
depuis quelques années qui est sûre les
figures du pouvoir et donc depuis 2008
mon projet c'est de photographier les
gens qui dans notre société ont le
pouvoir se veut pas dire grand chose le
pouvoir entre ce qu'on sait pas trop ce
que c'est moi j'ai cet alibi comme chez
un artiste je peux mettre dedans ce que
j'ai envie de m alors j'ai fait avant
des études de droit et sciences
politiques alors fait gars c'est pas
parce que c'est pas parce que vous êtes
ici en train de faire une fac
vous n'avez pas devenir artistes ou des
trucs un peu comme ça vos parents sont
hyper déçu parce que vous allez devenir
et est donc voilà donc j'ai photographié
d'abord le pouvoir ont dit régaliens
beaucoup de politiques et puis petit à
petit je me suis écarté de tout ça pour
aller dans des champs de pouvoirs divins
plus large
les financiers par exemple les patrons
les publicitaires etc
donc on peut se poser la question
pourquoi les puissants
habituellement ce qui me choquait ce qui
me frappe et ses convois de qu'une image
lisse en fait c'est les gens qui ne sont
représentés que sur un plan
communicationnel
j'ai fait de vous le faire le rythme va
très bien mais voyez le type les bras
croisés sur son bureau en faire on est
dans des poncifs comme ça de la
représentation je trouve ça incroyable
que notre monde d'aujourd'hui en fait on
en soit encore là et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est les visages or dans
ces représentations là on était dans une
espèce de deux noms incarnation des
chaires et je me disais mais allons les
rencontrer allons les représenter et
quand on parle pouvoir on peut aussi
parler d'influencé de notions qui
peuvent se mêler on pense habituellement
avait lieu à des institutions
éventuellement même à des signes
extérieurs mais on pense rarement à des
visages on pense bien sûr aux politiques
si je vous dis si tes mains des hommes
de pouvoir on connaît tous à peu près
les politiques qui nous entoure mais dès
qu'on s'écarte un petit peu de ce champ
là est bon on est perdu moi j'ai
commencé ce travail lors de l' affaire
kerviel
parce que soit sa formidable que le
métier de la finance dont on est tous
d'accord pour dire que c'est celui qui
nous gouvernent
le président actuel pourrait même dire
qu'il n'a qu'un an et demi sans nom et
sans visage est bien de ce métier là on
ne connaissait je ne connaissais que le
type qui s'était fait prendre la main
dans le pot de confiture
et puis le patron de la banque qui a
fini par démissionner quelques mois plus
tard quelques semaines plus tard et je
me suis mais voilà un sujet formidable
d'aller rencontrer ces gens là et de
voir à quoi ressemblait le visage c'est
la première porte d'accès à l'autre
c'est avec ça qu'on communique et
d'ailleurs mon injonction ce soir si je
peux me permettre ce serait de vous
regarder les uns les autres
enfin voila je vais revenir dessus après
tout à l'heure c'est avec le visage
qu'on séduit convainc qu'on soumet aussi
le visage il ya le regard sur lequel je
vais revenir et dans son travail dans le
travail que je fais sur les portraits
photographiques en fait je cherche les
traces du visage les traces que le
pouvoir peuvent laisser sur un visage et
pour le dire encore autrement
est ce que quand on pratique pendant
plusieurs années un métier de pouvoir
est-ce que ça marque les visages le
garçon que vous voyez là évidemment
c'est un mélange de deux photos agrippa
général romain gendre d'auguste et
nicolas dufour patron de la banque
publique d'investissement j'étais assez
étonné parce que j'ai fait c'est un peu
par hasard et si ça colle et pile poil
comme quand on a pas des masses changer
en 2011 et du coup on le voit bien là ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la chair qu'est-ce
qui incarne le pouvoir dans le visage
peut s'incarner principalement sur la
chaire là vous voyez un peu de vie un
peu ce que je fais pour moi le pouvoir
c'est une représentation c'est une mise
en scène au fond c'est un théâtre et moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de travailler
sur le masque social de la
représentation
je pensais jamais dans ma vie devoir
citer christine boutin mais mais il se
trouve que je vais quand même le faire
ce soir devant vous parce que lors de la
séance 1 elle m'a dit quelque chose de
formidable et je donc je vais la cité
dans la vie politique
les attaques on maîtrise mais ce n'est
pas le cas des images je me suis protégé
pendant dix ans des images pour ne pas
trouver que rien n'est plus beau
que sa propre image je trouve ça
vachement intéressant l'idée du mythe de
narcisse idée de plein de choses en fait
qu'ils sont mélangés à tout ça et
puisque tout à l'heure j'ai introduit la
notion de chair ces achats hier ce que
je vous ai déjà dit c'est que moi mon
sentiment c'est que le pouvoir se lit
sur les visages
bien plus que sur les corps qui au fond
une fois qu'on a enlevé le costume
cravate
on peut penser que chez les financiers
les rayures sont pas les mêmes que chez
les politiques etc
mais grosso modo quand même le la parra
reste le même
il fait attention à la manière dont on
est les un face à face aux autres quand
on parle à quelqu'un on le regarde on le
regarde dans les yeux
plus précisément on regarde un oeil
souvent l'oeil droit pour commencer et
on passe d'un oeil à l'autre par
ailleurs on a une distance de sécurité
alors ces pratiques parce que je peins
on est vachement loin mais je parle je
suis désolé je vous prendre comme comme
cobayes
mais voyez on a à peu près 1 m à 1 m 50
face aux gens et puis on se parle en
regardant les yeux
faites l'expérience maintenant pour un
peu troublé vos adversaires les
chasseurs de têtes et adore il adore
faire ça et vous serez un jour face à
ces gens là c'est qu'au fond ils
regardent plus les yeux mais ils vont
regarder le bo doit tenez votre front et
on se sent super mal et c'est quand même
étonnant parce qu'on est quand même en
train de regarder simplement le visage
maintenant autre chose bonjour si vous
rompez la distance de sécurité et que
vous vous rapprochez vachement près de
quelqu'un en regardant le coin de sa
bouche il va dire mettez envahi dégage
quoi j'ai un bout de salade enfin la
personne va se sentir super mal à l'aise
et moi je trouve ça passionnant c'est ce
que je cherche à montrer dans mes images
en étant près des gens et en montrant
les visages c'est au fond pourquoi est
ce que cette partie qui est nu en
permanence avec les mains et c'est les
soldes partie de notre corps qu'on a de
manière dénudées comme ça pourquoi
est-ce qu'au fond ça on n'aurait pas le
droit de le regarder
ou plutôt pourquoi est ce qu'on ne
pourrait le regarde et que de manière
relativement discrète
oui je lui en métro tout à l'heure vous
savez ça aussi bien que moi que vous
rentrez dans le métro pas fonds n'a
droit de jeter un regard mais on peut
pas regarder ce nom l'autre il dit tu
veux ma photo
kona enfin voilà mais et c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs l'analogie avec
la photographie voyez donc il ya quelque
chose là dans les visages qui est
intéressant à étudier et à travailler et
moi ce que je fais je suis plus du tout
j'en suis mais je vais finir par
retrouver le visage en fait c'est ce
qu'on offre aux autres en permanence et
évidemment il est nu on pourrait se
poser la question est ce qu'au fond les
visages pose problème de mon expérience
de ce que je viens de vous dire on
pourrait être tenté de dire relativement
oui et mon projet photographique au four
de photographier les gens de presse à
vous permet à vous ça nous permet à tous
de lire les images de manière hyper
précise et rigoureuse parce qu'on
photographie c'est formidable le type va
pas se barrer et où la fille pardon et
puis on peut faire ce qu'on veut il n'y
a pas d'interaction quoi et du coup vous
pouvez précisément regarder les parties
du visage et dans mes expositions
je varie la forme des tirages le type de
présentation mais des fois les tirages
sont assez grands donc la tête l espace
5 6 fois plus grande que nature et du
coup vous voyez tous les détails du
visage et faillirent défaut voyez comme
quoi on est on est on
on est mal embouché mais il ya quelque
chose là qui moi me fascine et me
passionne je pense qu'il faut creuser
les visages ils petite anecdote
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas pour rien que en
tout cas c'est pas sans raison face aux
visages que certaines sociétés voile le
visage des femmes et que nous ça nous
met si mal à l'aise il ya quelque chose
là autour des visages qu'il faut creuser
alors dans la droite ligne de cela moi
sur ma page et fâcherait recto verso
je suis frappé par la manière dont dans
notre société les images sont tout
retouché
c'est très rare les photos partout chez
vous avez compris par vous avez remarqué
que c'était pour trauma cam quoi moi je
j'aime bien parler retouchée et quant au
fond ce qui m'intéresse c'est de trouver
le masque est de voir qu'est ce qu'il ya
sur le masque et qu'est ce qu'il ya sous
le masque derrière le masque on a un
autre masque peut-être que de manière
symbolique ce que je cherche à faire
c'est à retourner le masque et je vais
aller assez rapidement mais voyez les
magazines féminins par exemple c'est ma
grande passion
ils ont jamais vraiment voulu travailler
avec moi je sais pas pourquoi mais c'est
que c'est des gens ou plutôt ces défis
qui à longueur d'article vous raconte
ben à 30 ans ben à 40 ans belle à 60 ans
rien à de mes grosses un de mes
petits sapins
voilà
je m'assume comme je suis quoi les
textes disent une chose qui est hyper
cohérente leur iconographie montre
exactement l'inversé
ça choque personne je veux dire en
couverture de elle vous avez une fille
qui a entre 14 et 80 ans elle a toujours
21 ans quoi et pour avoir des gens qui
font des retouches des fois pour moi je
dirais les retoucheurs appliquant fait
une fausse peau sur les peaux donc on a
on a des pores de la peau mais c'est pas
ceux de la personne quoi voilà qui avait
lieu le festival de cannes récemment
vous avez vu catherine deneuve et
compagnie dans dans dans ces choses là
et donc pour nous arrêter juste deux
secondes sur les masques cette
association m'intéresse parce que je
trouvais qu entre louis xiv et bhl au
fond la stratégie de communication était
relativement similaires alors on se
doute que l'on a copié l'autre mais mais
il ya quelque chose de fascinant et
d'intéressant et d'ailleurs si vous avez
l'occasion d'aller à versailles aller
voir ce masque en cire de louis xiv qui
ramasse qui fait du vivant du roi et
donc c'est une exacte empreintes du
souverain ya pas de copie voilà on est
dans la ville en tête de la photographie
moi je trouve ça incroyable vergès et je
le césar au fond je césar en vrai il
était chaud
il mettait ses cheveux un peu en avant
pour se cacher sa calvitie mais oui j'ai
passé le cap et r&d et je suis certain
il est plus là pour nous le dire et il
aurait certainement dit non mais ma
présomption c'est que vergès avec c'est
ce petit truc là où il se ramène ses
cheveux en avant comme comme les
premiers empereurs romains au fond ça
participe de ça je veux dire de cette
envie de pouvoir de cette envie de
d'adaptation à une société ce type qui
n'étaient pas nés en france
métropolitaine qui avait sans doute
vis-à-vis lui même besoin de se prouver
comme une appartenance à une communauté
voilà donc les images ça permet aussi ça
ça permet de lire des choses qui sont
présentes mais qu'on n'ose pas lire
quand on regarde les gens simplement
et puis vous voyez ma façon un peu
direct et brutale de photographier les
gens j'aime pas trop ce mot brutal mais
bon moi j'ai toujours pensé que la
photographie a particulièrement le
portrait que j'exerce et une relation de
pouvoir c'est à dire que c'est aux
photographes de prendre le pouvoir sur
son me photographier pour faire la
séance pour l'emmener là où ils veulent
emmener et donc
à un moment donné je me disais mais je
m'écoutais parler et puis je disais
toujours ma photo est en fait je suis
jamais sur la photo c'est toujours la
photo de quelqu'un d'autre ou quoi
maintenant j'essaie de faire à moitié
moitié j'ai mis de l'eau dans mon vin
comme on dit et du coup je dis notes
photos voilà et que ces étangs dans ce
sentiment d'appartenance alors qu'au
fond on n'y est pas et un moment donné
j'ai commencé à aller littéralement sur
la photo en disant mais si je pense que
c'est ma photo vas-y coco on va y aller
et donc à la fin de chaque séance il ya
un moment où je vais entre une et
plusieurs images et je me colle aux gens
et donc ce faisant je vous parlais du
regard sur les visages tout à l'heure et
de la distance physique oui c'est
quelque chose que l'on fait pas ça se
fait pas de regarder vraiment
attentivement quelqu'un alors le toucher
c'est encore pire coiffe ingéré s'est
pas non plus très très quelqu'un ne
connais pas je veux dire veille et que
quand je fais ces photos là j'ai connu
ma tête a eu et du coup qu'est ce qui va
se passer et ça m'intéresse parce que
moi je suis plus derrière l'appareil
j'ai quitté le lieu d'exercice du
pouvoir parce que derrière l'appareil
si la personne me fait sourire de keke
de communicants et ben je vais être là
pour le reprendre à l'ordre alors que là
j'ai quitté le lieu du pouvoir pour
aller à côté de la personne donc en
rentrant dans l'image en prenant le
pouvoir dans l'image en même temps je
les ai perdus donc voilà donc ça c'est
quelque chose que j'aime beaucoup faire
et que ça marche évidemment par séries
dans les expositions je montre un mur
entier avec ces photos là et donc les
gens se sont sans doute doivent se dire
mais c'est qui ce couillon qui change
toutes les photographies et puis après
ils peuvent s'ils doivent peut-être
reconnaître l'une ou l'autre des
personnes / / / leaf sur les photos et
qu' un des enjeux voyez ils ont tous des
réactions différentes quoi dhl et des
est fait comme si nous ne rien ne se
passe et d'autres sont dans une petite
hargne le garçon en haut à gauche et
cetera et cetera
voilà donc on peut faire le jeu des 7
familles en fête avec avec tout ça est
en fait ce que je fais ce que j'essaie
de faire avec tout ce travail c'est de
questionner la figure du pouvoir avec
l'outil même de sa représentation et de
son idéalisation l'image parce que tous
ces gens là passent leur temps à
utiliser les images de manière
évidemment communicationnel qu'est ce
qui se passe quand on les décale un
petit peu c'est un peu le but de mon
travail
et quand je quitte le champ de
l'appareil photographie c'est vous les
spectateurs du cou qui devenaient les
photographes parce que yakubu derrière
l'appareil et je vais finir parce qu'on
m'a dit qu'il fallait aller un peu vite
par seagate parce que j'aime bien que
c'est mon petit plaisir personnel est
toujours gardée petit plaisir personnel
mes souhaits ça assez juste par rapport
à tout ce travail la gaude qu'ils
disaient méfiez-vous des démons que vous
fuyez
ils sont peut-être le meilleur de vous
même et voilà et donc je voulais vous
remercier et puis je vous ai gardé une
petite surprise
je sais pas on sait pas on n'est pas sûr
que ça va marcher mais quitte à se
mettre tout nu autant y aller jusqu'au
bout avec le client la république qui
n'était pas encore président c'était
entre les deux tours de l'élection
quand je les photographie j'ai fait une
petite vidéo et et ça dure 2 minutes 30
et ça vous voilà
j'avais des langes voiture et salon
j'aide par rapport à la lumi avec toi
vite vite soissonnais lumière alors de
bien
on a passé trois ans voulait que dans
les accords voilà la lumière juste une
femme pas misé un peu la tête je vous
prie je vous remercie
je voulais d'abord il a à ce jour
d'acclamer type sa tête monsieur wayne
concentrons nous concentrons nous mais
c'est ça la nuit je suis vachement barre
en fait si vous l'avez si vous venez
face à moi tac roule rien et c'est comme
ça tout mandat comme ça c'est très bien
femmes femmes pas mais c'est plus la
tête s'il vous plaît laissez puisse
l'attaquer sur les molières ont sacré la
mâchoire un tout petit peu ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais
regardez ma main pam pam pam pam pam
objets qui flottaient kiffar 6-2 et
perso la jeunesse et le bruitage aa
attaques encore plus bas la tête ouais
voyez vous a fait face à moi
ça encore lui photo ok c'est fini tu
attaques concentriques on sentait qu'on
sentait plus bas plus un peu plus bas
s'il vous plaît ouais bah pas et a bien
écrit pas fait deux minutes en démontant
c'est quand même fou alors j'ai pas que
j'ai par contre dès que sa santé le
concentré de concentrer vous concentrez
concentrer la bcb cbcb seita on voit la
photo officielle en faut encore et vous
avez faire du sport
laissez moi
sayé lazare de retard